tu es nouveau groupe à l'assemblée
nationale devrait donc voir le jour
demain jusqu'où le groupe de la majorité
petit s'effriter c'est l'objet de notre
face à face prêt pour en débattre nous
sommes avec arnaud benedetti rédacteur
en chef de la revue politique et
parlementaire à ses côtés par skype
évidemment sébastien ferjou fondateur du
site atlantico bonsoir à tous les deux
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france un neuvième groupe donc l
assemblée écologie démocratie solidarité
ça veut dire une perte de majorité
absolue a plus que six sièges en du
seuil fatidique pour la république en
marche quelles conséquences concrètes
pour bien qu'on comprenne arnaud
benedetti ça signifie sur le plan de
l'arithmétique parlementaire comme vous
l'avez dit que le groupe majoritaire est
que la majorité et que le gouvernement
devra négocier
disons de manière régulière avec
l'ensemble des autres groupes qui
constituent la kz majoritaire le modem
notamment qui voit son poids politique
en l'occurrence augmenté du fait de
cette défection vers la gauche d'un
certain nombre de parlementaires de la
république a marre là où il faut
s'interroger c'est savoir si on est au
début d'un processus de désagrégation
progressive de la majorité qui mettrait
en péril même la survie parlementaire de
cette majorité où ils savent où
s'agit-il d'une forme de reformatage ou
de relookage de cette majorité avec une
aile gauche qui viendrait d'une certaine
manière redonner une identité un peu
plus à gauche à la république en marche
c'est une question que l'on peut se
poser que l'on pourra en verrez ça
bloque
véritablement il lucide et ou qu'on des
semaines et des mois qui viennent
sébastien ferjou ainsi nous dit voilà
j'aurais été va devoir composer est ce
que ça veut dire si on poursuit le
raisonnement jusqu'au bout que le
gouvernement va d'une certaine manière
devoir infléchir sa ligne je crois pas
que les gouvernements particulièrement à
composer avec ce nouveau groupe
moi je suis assez d'accord avec ce que
disait arnaud benedetti à l'instant à
savoir que ça va plutôt renforcer le
rôle du modem et dans une moindre mesure
du groupe du groupe agir mais ça remet
en quelque sorte françois bayrou au
centre du jeu parce que la promesse
première du maquereau nisme était ce
positionnement central est finalement
françois bayrou avait été obligé de
reconnaître qu'elle même macron lui
avait volé le mistigri en quelque sorte
eh ben c'est lui que ça va remettre plus
en situation de peser sur les décisions
du gouvernement parce que si on regarde
le groupe en question je ne crois pas
qu'il y ait de véritable demande dans
l'opinion correspondant à ce qu'il se
propose d'incarner d'autant que c'est un
groupe finalement assez disparate c'est
plus des gens qui sont dans le
mécontentement vis-à-vis pas forcément
d'ailleurs que la politique mais aussi
du fonctionnement du groupe à
l'assemblée
à l'assemblée nationale parce que je
crois que cette question là est assez
importante la manière dont gilles
legendre notamment a pu piloter ce
groupe n'a pas toujours été bien perçue
par un certain nombre de députés mais je
crois que ces gens là et on l'a vu
notamment avec la candidature de cédric
villani à paris ne sont pas forcément
des gens c'était un teaser sur des
thématiques qui peuvent être populaire
dans une certaine partie de l'opinion
mais qui ne se traduisent pas
nécessairement mécaniquement par des
voix dans les urnes où je pense que de
ce point de vue là et notamment parce
qu'il ya une échéance importante qui va
arriver avec le vote du budget 2009 21
il va falloir vraiment prendre des
décisions sérieuses je pense que le
modem sera plus en situation de peser
que le groupe en question a renommé ddt
vous n'y voyez pas une fragilisation des
manuels mettront il ya déjà eu une
quinzaine de départs successifs depuis
le début de la législature aujourd'hui
aurélien tâche et claque la porte
aussi la fondation de ce groupe avec des
anciens marcheurs à ce que ce n'est pas
justement la fin de l' eldorado qu'on a
vu au début ces marcheurs plein d'
enthousiasme qui finalement s'effrite au
fil
du temps et du catena oui alors si vous
voulez sur le plan de la mythologie de
la macro nice c'est la fin de cette
année aux ados comme vous l'avez dit qui
permettait de rassembler la droite et la
gauche sur le fond la sociologie
aujourd'hui électorale du maquereau
nisme c'est une sociologie qui a plutôt
dériver vers le sample droit donc en
l'occurrence eu cette dérive vers le
centre droit du maquereau nisme elle et
elle correspond à l'état en tous cas
d'une partie de l'opinion publique donc
si cette fragilité parlementaire peut
apparaître en effet comme un handicap
facialement pour cette majorité sur le
fond aujourd'hui clairement il s'agit
pas voulait semblablement de dix ans de
l'obstacle est sûrement table pour
l'exécutif s'est en effet quelque part
en matière d'image quelque chose qui
peut apparaître tout d'un coup comme une
ligne de fracture qui s'installerait à
l'intérieur de l'âme acronymes et la
macro n'y a depuis le début finalement
du mandat assumé globalement c'est azur
la main tôt vers le centre droit qui lui
a d'ailleurs plutôt réussi aux dernières
élections européennes donc en
l'occurrence c'est plus ceux disons un
problème d'image pour l'instant qu'un
problème des fonds politiques et de
fonctionnement jean sébastien ferjou on
a tous en mémoire ces frondeurs de
l'ailé gauche il ya pas si longtemps
autour d'un certain françois hollande
salue avait pas franchement porté chance
on ne voyait pas du tout de comparaison
vous mais probablement emmanuel macron
sera-t-il capable de tirer les leçons
justement de ce qui est arrivé à
françois hollande c'est à dire que
vraisemblablement on a accordé beaucoup
trop d'importance dans ce cas les
responsables de la majorité socialiste à
l'époque ont accordé beaucoup trop
d'importance à ces frondeurs qui n'avait
la vrai dire même pas d'unité véritable
entre eux c'était une espèce de création
mais d'éthique ou de créature médiatique
alors ça permettait aux frondeurs en
question d'avoir plus de surface parce
que forcément quand on est porteur d'une
parole suivante la demande
dia tic est parfois plus forte mais je
pense que françois hollande au contraire
à surestimer leur pouvoir de nuisance et
que s'il n'avait pas écouté les
frondeurs il ne s'en serait que mieux
porter quand vous regardez les résultats
électoraux
les frondeurs en question ont quasiment
tous été balayés lors des dernières
législatives ce qui montre bien que même
à gauche en tout cas sur un électorat
peut-être un peu plus à gauche il n'y
avait pas de demande pour ses fondeurs
là donc je pense que là la question elle
va être sensiblement la même pour les
gens qui sont dans ce groupe en revanche
ça pose quand même une difficulté alors
pas politique je suis d'accord avec ce
que disait renommée de benedetti
peut-être que tu as plus une difficulté
d'image c'est à dire en j'ai cru
comprendre qu'avec macron était en quête
de radicalité pour se réinventer pour la
deuxième moitié de son quinquennat c'est
plus difficile de revendiquer une
radicalité notamment une radicalité
peut-être sur le terrain l'environnement
si vous avez un matthieu orphelin qui
est un des députés proches de nicolas
hulot qui devrait avoir vocation à être
dans ce groupe aux côtés de delphine
batho l'ancien ministre de l'écologie
sociale
bref ce sera plus difficile de
revendiquer cette radicalité si vous
avez à côté un groupe qui ne cesse de
répéter oui mais regardez il ya que des
mots il n'y a pas de réalisation j'ai
justement aujourd'hui finir sur matthieu
orphelin aux benedetti cet écologiste on
ne rappelle proche de nicolas hulot
s'est dit quelque chose justement que
matthieu orphelin claque la porte avait
quelque chose du bilan écologique du
gouvernement mais cran selon vous ça dit
tout simplement que le packaging qui
était le packaging qui avait voulu
mettre en place
emmanuel macron avec une touche verte et
cette prise de guerre que constituait
nicolas hulot aujourd'hui nos perd plus
et ne fonctionne plus mais vous savez il
y à un grand nombre de promesses qui
était portée par emmanuel macron et sa
majorité qui ont disparu au fur et à
mesure du déroulement du monde à on peut
considérer que d'ailleurs la promesse
écologique
à dix on s'est dissoute depuis le départ
de nicolas hulot donc on est je pense
dans l'achèvement d'un processus qui se
traduit par le départ de ces gens qui
étaient de toute façon déjà orienté à
gauche et qui ne se retrouvent
vraisembablement
aujourd'hui dans le logiciel politique
et surtout dans la pratique plutôt
politique de d'emmanuel macron et de
l'exécutif et de la gestion également je
rejoins jean bastien jean sébastien
ferjou la gestion du groupe
parlementaire et donc on est là disons
avec une séquence qui est en train de se
clore mais qui encore une fois ne
constitue pas vraisemblablement une
rupture aussi fondamentale on peut
l'imaginer dans le fonctionnement de la
de la majorité le nom que cette majorité
ne va pas au devant de gros problèmes et
de grosses difficultés
mais ce n'est vraisemblablement c'est
pas la constitution de ce groupe
parlementaire qui aujourd'hui doit être
considérée comme disons une étape loin
tournant dans le monde à des manuels
macro il n'empêche
vous avez l'air de ne pas y voir une
grande menace mais enfin c'est quand
même assez critique hier du côté du
gouvernement cyber tendaï la
porte-parole évoquait un contresens
politique jean sébastien ferjou c'est
une critique de bon sens ou de mauvaise
foi bon je pense qu incontestablement
c'est une espèce de rupture avec la
première l'initiale du maquereau ni ça
montre bien que la promesse du
dépassement du dépassement du clivage
gauche droite elle n'a pas eu lieu donc
je comprends que parce que le mot de
dépassement est vraiment celui qui ont
employé les responsables de la majorité
pour disqualifier un peu ce groupe en
disant que c'était des gens qui
n'assument pas leurs responsabilités et
qui n'assumait pas le mandat finalement
sur lequel il avait été vu puisque là
d'un programme en particulier il y avait
cette promesse du dépassement des
clivages habituels
donc moi je suis entièrement d'accord
avec ce que disait arnaud b des litiges
je pense que le sujet pourrait même
accru pour la majorité il est dans
l'opinion et dans la défiance on nous
voit dans l'opinion on a vu ces derniers
jours quelques images du présent la
république confronté de vraies paroles
de défiance notamment des soignants dix
ans mais quoi qu'il annonce finalement
il a de la peine à convaincre les
français que les actions vont suivre les
paroles la création de ce groupe là
politiquement elle n'a pas grande grande
importance en revanche l acte quand même
le fait que la promesse initiale du
maquereau nice elle s'est un peu
évaporée et que le président
est en quête de réinvention en quelque
sorte d'un adn politique à la fois pour
la fin de ce quinquennat et pour une
éventuelle candidature en 2022 parce
qu'il ne pourra plus refaire le coup en
quelque sorte qui lui a réussi du
dépassement du simple déplacement du
clivage gauche droite ça ça ne sera plus
possible maintenant
merci à tous dès 2h nos benedetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire jean sébastien ferjou
fondateur du site atlantico merci à tous
les deux